well there's only two ways to solve a
problem stop dwelling and start doing hi
my name is Daniel Amed and I live in the
Dallas Fort Worth area in early 2022 I
decided to enroll in the business
analysis program partnered with simply
learn completing this program help
improve my analytical skills and my
business acument not to mention improve
my salary by 15% in the marketplace with
over 5 years of fostering vendor client
relationships representing Fortune 00
companies I developed a strong business
acument with an array of transferable
skills to further sharpen my analytical
skills the postgraduate in business
analysis partnered with Purdue
University from Simply learn has been
the best decision for me from a
professional perspective program
equipped me with analytical skills and
business acument and Technical acument
as well as stakeholder dexterity which
helped me leverage data driven insights
the learning experience with simply
learn was fantastic there are a number
of professors who have real world
experience in addition to your
colleagues the course helped me land my
dream job as a sales operations analyst
since taking the business analysis
course would simply learn my long-term
career goals are growing stronger every
day I believe that learning is a
lifelong process so keep at
[Music]
it